the governor one of the one of the
slower ones to shut things down is now
one of the first to open things up on
the stay-at-home order we understand
expires on April 30th and we saw at
Jack's Beach yesterday for the most part
when they were opened when the beaches
were open for two separate ships during
the day it won pretty well governor what
went into that decision and what's next
for Florida well we have a great task
force with people from all over the
state of Florida and all the different
industries particularly small business
and we're putting together a lot of
great ideas for what the next phase
looks like in Florida but you know I got
to give credit to the people of Florida
you go back six weeks everybody
particularly in the Acela media was
saying Florida was going to be worse
than New York obviously we have a very
elderly population it was constant
people saying that if you look at what's
happened that's not true
you know New York for example has about
25 times the number of fatalities of
Florida even though we have two million
more people right now as of last night
we had about 730 people statewide in the
ICU people said our hospitals were going
to be overrun we've actually increased
hospital bed space and ICU bed space
during the pandemic so there were fewer
beds available in Florida in February
than there are now so Florida's
flattened the curve people have done a
great job and I think the I think we
understand that you can do both you can
continue to fight kovat 19 but also get
people back to work and have society
function again in Bryan I never did
draconian orders here like you see in
some of these other states where a dad
would get arrested for or get cited for
taking his daughter to the park that
doesn't work we've never done that we've
been very I think reasonable with the
people of Florida and they've responded